- Family is very important.
Like when my daughter,
she's eight years old
right now I'm teaching her
the basic coping mechanisms
to deal with how she feel inside.
- [Kelly] Yeah, especially
in the past year-
- I don't look at my daughter
and talk to my daughter
and say, "What's wrong?"
I don't say that.
I say, "How you feel?"
I give her an opportunity to tell me
how she's feeling inside.
- Yeah.
- So, 'cause the way she feels is real
and it matters.
- Yeah, and we forget that kids feel,
like, so intensely.
(crowd applause)
- They know love, they know love.
- Yes.
- I know love.
I remember when I was younger.
- Yeah.
- I had no love in my
neighborhood like that.
- Yeah.
- My mother bought me some sneakers,
some Puma's, and Puma's was hot then.
(Kelly laughs)
I went to the public pool
in the neighborhood.
And they broke in my locker
and they stole my Puma's.
And I went home and I had a nice meal,
and I went back the next day like I was
revenging my brother's death.
(Kelly laughs)
- And I (beep) in the pool.
They shut it down.
- I'll show you.
- 'Cause of bacteria.
(Kelly laughs)
They shut it 'cause they had
nowhere to play that summer.
(Kelly laughs)
And it was "Do the Right Thing" hot.
I mean, "Do the Right Thing" hot.
And I ain't care, I want my sneakers back.
And ever since I seen that,
ever since that happened,
whenever I see water, it
triggers me to (beep).
(Kelly laughs)
So I was playing in a Johnny Pump
and I (beep) in the street.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- And the bus ran over my (beep).
- My (beep).
- And then my neighbors
bought a Slip N' Slide it up,
and I'm (beep) on that
for no apparent reason.
Just to do it.
- [Kelly] Just you're a rebel. (laughs)
- Don't play with me.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Took my sneakers.
- That's the worse.
- I'm not having it.
- That's the worse though.
- I shut it down.
- Oh my God.
(Kelly laughs)
- Until I get my sneakers back,
these kids ain't playing nowhere.
(crowd laughs)
- Leave a note by the (beep).
- Return my sneakers
and I'll stop.
- That's right.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, wait, wait, you're-
- You know my style, y'all know my style.
- There is no segue way. I love it.